I try not to do videos that are just
look at this thing but look at this
thing this is bounce below at the slate
cabins in bland of the synagogue in
Wales it's three enormous trampoline net
on three levels in a slate cabin and
there are people above me and people
below me I am standing above a 100-foot
drop on a trampoline
I try not to videos or just look at this
thing this is incredible there are
ladders and chutes and slides made of
metal
if you're scared of heights this may not
with a thing to you
but whoever thought of installing
trampolines and ladders and shoots in a
slight torreón whales you are a genius
it's like a cathedral made with netting
it's amazing
[Applause]
there's a shoot I can drop down here
it's just a hole in the night I'm doing
that again today I'm exhausted
that was Moundsville oh there's nothing
you should have known here just
somewhere you really should go too
you